did you we're not gonna say the name of
it or anything like that but you you saw
that that tick-tock I sent you from that
that from the house
oh yeah life yeah yeah yeah yeah we we
man we came across an actual El house
and we cannot we cannot it is so good -
oh my god it's bad oh my god is bad bro
another perfect none of them in dance
and they're all let me promise you this
they are swag liss0 drip dude and that's
mean to say I feel like a real [ __ ]
saying that but I [ __ ] swear on my
life it is universal anyone would look
at this and go oh man what the [ __ ] dude
it's like it's like they copied all the
e boy tropes but they don't do it good
enough you know I mean they don't have
they don't have it no it's like they do
this center part but they leave too much
hair on it's like it's just a little bit
off so weird
they're like always a little bit offbeat
yeah they're using jokes wrong it's in
light sir how funny you could tell like
there's a degree of it's it's like
there's a palpable insecurity it like
yeah and in the movements like they're
like there's nothing worse than an
insecure [ __ ] boy I mean but yeah like a
guy a guy shyly licking between his
fingers his legs
it's worse than creepy you just feel
really bad for him yeah yeah I totally
agree yeah if you're a [ __ ] boy you
gotta own it yeah you might as well I'm
just thinking about them like making
that motion like lick between their
fingers but then like they get cold feet
and so like they just kind of like kiss
where the [ __ ] would be in stock that's
creeping me out
yeah or like cryin just laughing
oh my god yeah make that [ __ ] read
bronzes do is tick-tock
he didn't get a lot of views but then he
did the he did the Kevin gates sound
ain't nothing to [ __ ] yo [ __ ] though
like he did that and it went off so he
okay
he tried a few other sounds and you know
he dropped back to his previous
engagement
so he did the sound again and it banged
again and I was just like crying
laughing at the idea of you know hitting
a few and being like let me just go back
to what I know back then what I know
that's so funny
and they're just repeatedly doing that
sound that's it it's like an artist it's
gonna artists finding his sound yeah
or her sound it's like that but it's
like finally finally I found what work
yeah works for me I don't want to be the
guy that's just doing the Kevin gates
sound all the time alright I need to try
more things dude it's like all the top
people will do oh well dude if a dance
pops I'll just do it over and over and
over and over again and it's the same
every time yeah oh but it's just have
you been on the talk you've been on
there
what do you mean been on the talk like
he just browse it like you're just on
there yeah yeah man what else is there
to [ __ ] do right now
mmm okay there's some funny [ __ ] on
there I haven't I've not been on not
been on I've been yeah I've been an
active user for the past couple weeks
I've been playing the new Cod that [ __ ]
is I've never played a Call of Duty in
my life and you like it I do it's fun so
it's a great great franchise I just on
the day that you guys booted it up and
started playing together that was the
day I had uninstalled it I just needed
extra [ __ ] space on my hard drive
it's 90 gigs or whatever so I did a dude
that's massive
and I know I'm just not gonna read I
can't I pulled a four-night again I
played with Sam and I was like I don't
know I felt you know I felt myself
getting sucked back in a little bit
a fortnight is yeah I'm not gonna talk
about it it's a game it's a good game
for kids it's a game for kids I feel bad
that I ever gave a single [ __ ] about
that game how did I just fall for the
kids game of the generation how did I
just fall you're saying call duty that's
a man's game yeah bro it's a gamers game
so what's up with war zone is it looks
like that's the same thing um all right
we're doing this okay fair so I've never
played Call of Duty before so Sam tells
me it's similar in some of the mechanics
and most people play Call of Duty feel
like it's the same game it's just a
battle royale so you drop in but but I
think they figured out interesting ways
to keep it it always feels like there's
action so they took the aspect of
Counter Strike for when you kill someone
you get money and you can get money in
game and the money it within war zone is
called CP which is unfortunate acronym
Sam was like what does that mean coin
points yeah so every time you kill
someone you get some CP isn't that nice
Jesus [ __ ] a little bit all right let me
stop that bit so one of the challenges
is called pizza gate it's really fun and
you can go to this island you go this
little island on this plane and the
flight records are deleted about anyone
knowing you went to those to this island
and there's actually celebrity cameos on
that island
[Laughter]
oh my god dude so you kill someone you
get CP okay
and no but this is actually dope so the
money lets you buy a certain [ __ ] like
you can buy better guns you can you can
buy self revive and so that I think
that's a big one is you can get self
revive and then let's say you die before
you can purchase a self revive you go to
a gulag where you can one-on-one someone
for the chance to respawn so if you win
you go back into the game and you can
like meet up with whoever and then if
you die again your friends can get money
and buy you back and like respawn you in
the game so it's like it it's not like
fortnight where you're [ __ ] waiting
forever to just play for two minutes
like it's just constant action yeah
that's pretty safe so I think that
aspect of it is what keeps people in it
it's because it's it's just it's more
flow it's like a battle royale - yeah
so you're still dropping the thing that
Sam came up with we did this one stream
yesterday I was [ __ ] hysterical is
wouldn't we drop out of a plane well
like Sam will pick someone because what
it is as you're dropping in you spawn
with a pistol so we'll cut our
parachutes and we'll it will shoot a
person in the sky so it forces them to
panic drop and so the three of us follow
him down and then by the time he's on
the ground he's low health and we just
melee him and the melee is just punching
so we're just jumping him he's like
trying to kill us but we I want someone
down when someone goes down you can hear
their in-game mic it's proximately
microphone so you can hear them like
screaming and like getting so pissed off
and for like two seconds so like you're
just beating the [ __ ] out of them
they're like do what and then they just
kick it's cutting in and out
hey kids so you can hear their mic when
you're close to them yeah just when
they're down what that's sick dude is so
[ __ ] funny it's so yeah [ __ ] dude
dude we're in yesterday and these two
dudes were like swapping weapons and
like in the open area and I just like
clack them both and one of them oh wait
wait wait war zone is called duty it's
the same game yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is the one you've been playing yeah
it's Call of Duty war zone oh my [ __ ]
god [ __ ] it's stupid I thought there
were two different oh oh I'm an idiot
dummy straight dummy over here bro oh my
god it's it's the funniest thing ever
it's so goddamn funny damn it I want to
play yeah no he should 175 gigabytes
available hard drive space aren't there
mine
somebody's on today boys yeah it's good
though man
you